[Música]
a pesar de que el ejército de rusia es
muy superior al ucraniano las fuerzas de
vladimir putin han encontrado una
resistencia importante en su intento por
llegar aquí y avanzar por ucrania según
analistas militares rusia estaría
optando por una estrategia aérea antes
de una ofensiva real terrestre para así
acorralar a ucrania y evitar que tenga
una mayor amplitud para organizarse y
movilizar sus tropas
de esta manera moscú puede entonces
consumar rápido la invasión e impedir
que llega a kiev toda la ayuda militar
que ha prometido occidente dándole más
respuesta bélica a los ucranianos y para
ello entonces quiero saludar en este
momento a nuestro segundo invitado el
día del s llegó rodríguez analista
militar y director de política de brun
gracias
thiago por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 en su opinión cuál
sería la estrategia militar empleada por
rusia en esta invasión a ucrania
bueno en un primer momento han intentado
abrir la guerra en todos los ejes
posibles crimea el donbass hardcore kiev
para intentar obligar a los ucranianos a
estar centrados en muchos lugares y en
ese momento lanzar un gran asalto aéreo
contra la capital que la capital kiev es
el auténtico objetivo final el centro de
gravedad digamos del ejército ucraniano
sin embargo ese asalto aéreo del día 1 y
2 básicamente un fracaso total que en
estos momentos están teniendo que
reajustar su estrategia va a ser mucho
más costosa y ahora mismo ya están
poniendo toda la carne en el asador para
tomar sobre todo quiere aunque en el
frente sur en la zona de crimea también
hay combates pues muy bueno más que
crimea el mar de azov no digamos hay
combates muy serios entonces llegó este
lento avance de las tropas rusas puede
leerse como un problema logístico como
usted lo está hablando falta de
combustible errores de cálculo que
realmente estaría pasando con este
avance lento de las tropas rusas porque
se esperaba que ya digamos se hubieran
tomado que pero no lo han hecho todavía
bueno en los dos primeros días cabe
decir que el avance no fue lento fue muy
rápido y en estos momentos al fin y al
cabo llevamos unos cinco días de guerra
en un país como ucrania no se puede
conquistar en tan poco tiempo entonces
si los rusos consideran que están siendo
lentos es porque eran demasiado
optimistas inicialmente y por eso a mí
entender el principal problema que están
encontrando ahora es reajustarse es
decir han intentado algo muy rápido han
lanzado sus columnas de blindados a toda
velocidad exponiendo las emboscadas ya
su destrucción con tal de ganar algunos
kilómetros pero en estos momentos los
ucranianos están demostrando enfrentarse
bien esas columnas probablemente tienen
inteligencia de países occidentales como
francia eeuu que les permite saber por
dónde vienen las columnas y en buscarlas
y por eso en estos momentos ya rusia
está empezando a frenar y está empezando
a movilizar su artillería sus medios más
pesados y avanzar de una manera más
lenta y más metódica pero con menos
bajas subestimar o entonces los rusos a
los ucranianos le preguntó además si son
suficientes todas estas armas que le han
entregado a los estadounidenses y los
europeos como los misiles antitanques
por ejemplo y con esta ayuda que también
prometieron que iba a seguir llegando
serían suficientes para enfrentarse a un
ejército tan numeroso y tan grande como
el ruso
bueno respecto a la primera pregunta si
parece que de alguna manera les
subestimaron como mínimo fueron
excesivamente optimistas sobre todo en
ese asalto contra kiev y en cuanto a la
segunda pregunta todo ese material
estadounidense sin duda todo eso ayuda
aunque yo diría que la clave realmente
es la inteligencia estratégica que se
les esté dando estratégica y táctica es
decir por dónde viene la columna rusa
cuántos vehículos vienen como es de
importante y por tanto dónde puedo
prepararle una buena en buscada
infligirles muchas bajas no obstante
todo esto al final va a depender de la
voluntad ucraniana de combatir y de
cuantos cuánta carne va a poner rusia en
el asador que parece que va a ser toda
la necesaria para tomar que es claro
thiago y también pues en estas guerras
actuales hay un término que se llama
guerra híbrida y ahí también empieza a
jugar la desinformación los rusos
apelaron a esto precisamente para
justificar su invasión a ucrania
diciendo que la querían es
desmilitarizar y también desclasificar
como lo conversamos con nuestro primer
invitado como está todo esto y cómo
están los sistemas de comunicación rusos
al frente
la guerra
bueno desde el punto de vista de la
guerra híbrida debo decir que es un
concepto que se ha puesto de moda pero
en realidad nadie sabe muy bien lo que
significa significa muchas cosas y en
general lo que mucha gente cree que
significa no tiene nada que ver con lo
que originalmente se pensaba que era
pero bueno yendo al campo de batalla
informativo que es en el que se lleva
combatiendo desde que hay medios y hay
prensa y radio en estos momentos rusia
ha accedido
completamente en la partida a ucrania
porque les resulta prácticamente
imposible
justificar la invasión ni siquiera entre
los propios rusos no es que no lo
intenten pero los argumentos y la
realidad son no se pueden no son
manipulables en este caso porque son muy
claras
también hay entre la guerra cibernética
los rusos también son expertos en hacer
esto ellos están también tratando de
hacer una guerra en el ciberespacio iago
a su parecer
sí sí completamente naturalmente dentro
de toda la ofensiva se emplean todos los
medios posibles y desde luego que se
estarán produciendo importantes
ciberataques contra ucrania no cabe
ninguna duda bien es cierto que quizás
no han sido tan eficaces como cabría
esperar debido a que eeuu ha estado
apoyando bastante ucrania en esta
materia ahora el plan de rusia es ocupar
completamente ucrania cambiará el
gobierno y quedarse como lo usted
digamos digamos cuál es el final además
además de quiere luego de tomar kiev que
viene
después de tomar kiev en función del
coste que haya tenido quien y el
desgaste que haya supuesto ocuparán yo
creo temporalmente una parte muy
importante ucrania kiev harkov lo que
haga falta con tal de conseguir un
acuerdo un tratado o como mínimo un
cambio de régimen en ucrania empieza en
el gobierno naturalmente y por tanto
será una ocupación relativamente corta
yo no esperaría que dure mucho más de
unos meses un año a lo sumo la única
parte del país en la que creo que podría
haber una ocupación y a una anexión
permanente es el corredor que uniría
crimea con el donbass la zona de
mariupol meditó por toda esa área ahora
rusia como lo vemos y cómo lo sabemos
desde un país militarmente fuerte pero
económicamente débil y más con todas
estas sanciones que tanto puede resistir
rusia ante todas estas sanciones
económicas
rusia puede tratar de resistir mucho
tiempo y al fin y al cabo se trata de si
la contestación interna llega a provocar
pues un golpe de estado contra putin
nuevos y algo que aún pese a la dureza
de las sanciones por soy nos parece
difícil y de todas maneras hay que
pensar que la clave aquí es la duración
de las sanciones europeas es decir una
vez rusia conquisté quiere o una vez
rusia se retire de ucrania de aquí a
unos meses vamos a mantener esas
sanciones vamos a arriesgarnos a tener
un problema con el gas el próximo
invierno que es el momento ideal de los
rusos para presionar qué papel va a
jugar china va a amortiguar mucho ese
golpe económico bueno pues aún hay
muchas incógnitas a despejar
pues incógnitas que solamente vamos a
responder a medida de que avanza este a
medida de que pasan los días ya hago
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa realmente un
placer haber conversado con usted
vosotros